[Music]
touchdown New England
Antonio Brown
the newest Patriot it was less than a
week ago that super star wide receiver
Antonio Brown looked like he would be
headlining a seemingly unstoppable
offense for the New England Patriots but
on Friday the defending Super Bowl
champs cut Brown after he had played
just one game for them the move came
after a second woman had accused him of
sexual misconduct the New England
Patriots shocked the football world when
they signed Antonio Brown less than two
weeks ago the talented but controversial
wide receiver had just been released by
the Oakland Raiders
despite the team signing him to a 50
million dollar contract this year but a
day after he joined New England Browns
former trainer 28 year old Brittany
Taylor filed a civil lawsuit alleging he
sexually assaulted her three times
including a violent rape at his Miami
home last year Taylor sat down with NFL
investigators on Monday for 10 hours
that same day
Sports Illustrated published an account
by another woman who says Brown made
unwanted sexual advances toward her in
2017 after he hired her to paint a mural
in his house Thursday night Sports
Illustrated reported that same woman
received an intimidating group text
allegedly from Browns telephone which
included pictures of her and her
children
the texter accused the woman of
fabricating her story for cash during
his Friday morning news conference
Patriots coach Bill Belichick told
reporters he wouldn't comment on any of
Browns off-the-field issues when the
questions continued I'm good okay thank
you
Belichick abruptly ended the session
hours later Brown was off the team and
the Patriots released a statement
reading in part we feel that it is best
to move in a different direction at this
time the NFL is investigating the claims
against Brown and could suspend him his
agent says that Brown is looking forward
to playing in the NFL again and as it
works out I happen to be doing sidelines
for their game on Sunday the Patriots
game as the broadcast team we were at
practice yesterday the only ones there
and I can tell you Antonio Brown
practice the entire time so at least to
us it did not look like he wouldn't be
playing no indication yeah just out of
the blue I mean they had been
investigating in these reports were out
there Bill Belichick said at his news
fronts that they were looking into
things but at least we know this much he
was practicing with the team yesterday
we will see if he hooks up with another
team now at any point if you're taking a
lot with that